this is a production of Cornell
University
well Thank You Neil
as Neil mentioned I had retired this is
a personal thought modern technology
really messes up retirements people can
find me over the internet whatever and
the number of questions that get asked
and pretty much the questions end up
falling into certain specific categories
like aquaculture our LEDs and one that's
really a popular question relates to
urban farming and particularly the old
favorites in urban farming skyscraper
farms or abandoned warehouses there's a
real fascination with abandoned
warehouses and when I first got these
questions I began to think of some of
this doesn't make sense does it really
make sense so trying to put some numbers
with it and that's what I'm gonna do
today is go through just simple
calculation simple ways that a technical
person should look at some of these
ideas and at the end of it make up your
own mind I don't have a specific agenda
straight thank you for saying in any way
trying to put numbers try to put some
logic to the question of is urban
farming in this kind of a system
worthwhile and what really characterizes
these systems is the dependence on
artificial supplemental light non
sunlight so we're talking about urban
plant factories sort of a generic term
for this very common are they high in
the sky or are they pie in the sky
and I think what you decide we're really
talking about skyscraper farms you see
these mention on the Internet
up to 60 stories tall various crops
grown in them the more ambitious people
try to grow trees and cows things like
that in the skyscraper the next one
abandoned warehouses love to fill
abandoned warehouses with plants because
what else you're gonna do with an
abandoned warehouse one might guess tear
it down and start over but they want to
use it over again and are there really
is that an emperor wearing new clothes
or not is the question now there a lot
of proposals a lot of designs have been
developed to show to create vertical
farm facilities and it just it strikes
me there must be enormous fun to be an
architect more fun than any other
profession because you can invent these
things that don't have to do anything
because you can let your imagination
flow and some of the ideas on the roof
but also in the building in other these
are all architectural drawings they're
not for real or a big skyscraper like
this or one like this or this one you
can't read the icons but they talk about
what can be grown there and this is a
cherries peaches grapes fodder all sorts
of things that proposed to grow them
there this one is the plant agon in
Sweden is that skyscraper they're trying
to sell to various cities or
municipalities it's a very tall 60 story
tall skyscraper with plants this is one
is also a plant agon it's a circular
greenhouse the plants are put in one end
and there's a ramp that circles up and
the plant goes up or else goes down put
on his seeds on one end harvested crop
on the other end
what makes this interesting as the
Onondaga Nation is I believe purchased a
significant portion of their investment
money put a lot into this particular
idea to sell these things some of the
more imaginative designs if you like
something like this as dag pebbles this
is specifically designed to be a stacked
pebble green house if you like that this
one is called the dragonfly for some
reason being very promoted for placement
of one of these on Roosevelt Island in
New York City we know that's where
Cornell is a tech campus I don't think
there's a common is any reason for it
but coincidence but that's one of the
more the most imaginative sorry want to
go through a number of things and talk
about this some background on vertical
farm concepts reality check on the crops
that can be grown because the crops that
can be grown have been proposed that
said for all sorts of things and one of
the primary motivations for some of the
enthusiasts is to return farm land to
the primordial state to get rid of all
farmland and grow over all of our crops
in vertical farms cost comparison
related to photosynthetic lighting in a
vertical farm how much does it cost you
to write to run a hundred percent lights
versus using the Sun this one is the one
that's the untold story really and
nobody seems to want to listen to it
it's the how large is the carbon
footprint these concepts are motivated
by the desire to do away with food miles
the large carbon footprint associated
with food miles so let's grow the plants
locally let's grow them in an abandoned
warehouse does it make sense promised
the more efficient lighting to talk
about LEDs a little bit talk about
renewable energy people say well I don't
worry about electricity because I'm
going to put in foot PV panels let's
look at that critically and see if it's
possible other ways to ed light and
these are all proposed for that mirrors
concentrating mirrors light pipes fiber
optics
all of these high-tech ways of currents
reflecting carrying transmitting light
look at that and then I want to be a
little bit positive and end on the idea
that there are some places where this
might make sense
it all goes well questions and
discussion and notice I don't say
answers just questions and discussion
now the current book that you may have
heard about is the vertical farm book by
Dixon dysphonia from Columbia University
who's not a green house person at all
he's a microbiologist and he I have a
number of quote several quotes in there
some I agree with and some I talk the
first is we know how to proceed we can
apply hydroponic and aeroponic farming
methodologies to a multi-story building
and create the world's first vertical
farms I'm not sure we know how to
proceed but what's also a little bit
irritating is that the numbers he uses
to promote his system are our own
numbers applied inappropriate leak this
one I do agree with should be cheap to
build modular durable easily maintained
safe to operate independent of economic
subsidies and outside support so that's
important but he admits that but he also
says no ecosystem can exceed the limits
of bio whoops
biomass production strictly limited by
the amount of incoming energy and that
means slight if you're growing up plants
in a building heat is one thing but
light is the really important first part
to think about so these are all those
are things I agree with let's see if it
really is true in his design now
there's a lot of skepticism about this
I'm not the only one in the world a
skeptical and growing plants in these
different facilities they doubt the
practicality now this slide this picture
everybody know what this plant is
lettuce head lettuce Bibb lettuce this
middle Vitus year ago I got an email
from he was from Scranton Pennsylvania
and I think it's still going on he had
an abandoned warehouse that he could
convert it to growing lettuce put some
skylights in the roof
this was his crop and he asked me what
nutritional factor is at play here
octonal manganese white obviously white
but this is the kind of thing that
people don't make any real connection to
is the amount of light that a plant
needs because the plant is so linear
with respect to the light and the eye is
so nonlinear that you can see very well
in a low light that will plant them
fairly at the compensation point the
plant at a compensation where is enough
light that you can see very well
so tackling some of the dials one at a
time
potential crops greens herbs possible
vine crops small fruits tree crops the
next level of proposal wheat corn
soybeans the next level to return wind
does primordial state is that possible
let's look at the claim that wheat is
possible just picked at a crop at random
let's look at the economic viability of
cea wheat production as a metric the
world record for outdoor wheat
production as one comparison done in
2010 in New Zealand 233 bushels per acre
Neil said I grew up in a farm a new
field I think that our acreage our Weald
was about 10% of this that much per acre
this is the record outdoor/indoor the
most I've seen is work that's been done
by Bruce Bugbee and Frank Salisbury Utah
State looking at wheat production for
NASA trying to push the limits how far
can they go how much light can they give
it and how much growth can they get this
was just the result that this was
looking at wheat with three tillers
primary secondary tertiary tillers this
was the yield from each one as a
function of daily light integral now
talk about daily light integral is you
know in moles per square meter per day
or talk about Dwight in generals micro
moles per meter squared per second
adding these three together you get a
line that looks like this
the dealed as a function of daily light
integral it goes up 250 the wheat is
still increasing well what's 150 moles
per square meter per day you have a good
feeling for a sec No
this the maximum that's that I could
find ever for anything over 64 believe
it or not this is 14 years of it
occurred whether dater solar data this
is the day lease moles per square meter
and these are the day of the year and
these are measured data from the cournot
weather station for 14 years 83 to 96
and you can see on this this bounding
curve is outside the atmosphere and all
the little dots are individual days pick
like 55 this is a good number to pick
sort of in the middle of the graph you
can see it is achievable this line is 55
so it became my guess as a place to make
an analysis you know what we're doing as
well as well do an ethic at just about
any day of the year
better than most starting April 20th
ending August 8th is when you pass that
maximum possible at 55 so let's assume
we will grow crops within this
greenhouse at 55 moles per square meter
per day daily light integral now I
defended to make gunner to present a
number of things in these sort of
flowcharts so I hope you like flowcharts
and told that it's easier to understand
than a series of equations so let's look
at two possibilities record field
production the 1.5 6 7 etc a yearly high
intensity growth chamber they could do
for crops a year Bruce could do floor it
was a dwarf wheat to a very high
intensity production in a dwarf wheat to
kilograms per square meter per harvest
at 55 let's say we have four harvests
the four harvest with the high intensity
grow through them getting far more than
the outdoor production so we'll take
four harvests we'll assume we can
harvest four times a year eight
kilograms per square meter per year
we're one point six four pounds per
square foot that's the best I thought we
could probably do with wheat
what's the value of wheat these are some
of the year old data but I looked
yesterday and there's wheat prices have
stayed very similar very consistent over
the years 12 and a half cents a pound is
the world wheat price do that
so over Nev cents a pound I 1.64 pounds
per square foot per year 20 cents per
square foot per year is the income will
we replace outdoor agriculture gross in
really you connect anything that's a
commodity you must have something more
valuable than any commodity so corn
wheat I said are not possible cannot
replace outdoor agriculture the same as
answers come up if you look at we corn
soybeans any of the commodity crops well
that's one perspective is how much
income you get the other perspective is
the cost what's the cost of electricity
to run this facility to grow the wheat
let's assume we have good efficient
lighting high pressure sodium good LEDs
yearly income 20 cents per square foot
what's the electricity bill rather than
saying what's the electricity bill I
wanted to ask the question what's the
cost of the electricity to bake one loaf
of bread
to grow the wheat for one loaf of bread
can relate to that we bake some bread
the things I weren't doing this it's
amazing never bacon never baked bread
never ever baked bread in my life one
kilogram of wheat 1.3 liters of kernels
two point six litres of flour because
flour eggs a lot of airspace three point
seven loaves of bread out of one
kilogram of leek okay I hope everybody's
taking this down so 55 moles per square
meter times 365 days 20,000 moles per
square meter core no data for high
pressure sodium we did a test of a
different high pressure sodium lamp some
years ago and generally got the number
that we get for moles of light from a
luminaire for moles for every kilowatt
hour that went into it now these were
400 watt lights 600 to be slightly
better a thousand slightly better but
you're not gonna get about four so three
seems to characterize a lot of the
lighting and it characterizes LEDs so we
have sixty six hundred CCS Evans
kilowatt hours per square meter per year
let's assume the electricity is 10 cents
a kilowatt hours depends 687 dollars of
cost for a square meter per year we have
the productivity we know one kilogram
produces 3.7 volts we can bake 29.6
loaves out of this square meter and we
picked lectric bill of $23 a loaf I
tended to pick generous assumptions and
even with the generous assumptions at
this point at $23 the loaf I got rather
concerned I will sit so commodities
won't pay so look at an odd commodity
crop look at in this case lettuce would
use that model as being the greenhouse
that challenge industries runs out by
nice Agassi see a greenhouse from
several years ago that was given to
challenge by Cornell the productivity at
the time it was build we were planning
on 1245 heads per day from the system
total hits per day I talked with the
assistant manager a couple of weeks ago
and he said he's been counting there's
been about 12 40 so it's not a bad
assumption
a couple get thrown out of course so we
have that much and these are 150 to 160
gram heads so what's the extra cost of
total closure that's the green house
will be totally closed and which means
100% artificial light now people who
object to the concept of artificial
light because all light is real what's
the term that's used productivity 17
balls per square meter per day that is
the daily right integral that's imposed
on the lettuce to prevent it burn and to
maximize growth optimize growth two
possibilities hundred percent
supplemental light or 30 percent why 30
percent well based on the data that we
have over a year that green house
receives 70 percent of its light from
the Sun and even an if occur 30 percent
from the electricity we have the three
moles per kilowatt hour or the efficacy
and hey I use the word efficacy rather
than the efficiency because the unit's
are not the same top and bottom 689
kilowatt hours per square meter per year
with the greenhouse 2068 with the closed
system
productivity as given before we get 0.9
one kilowatt hours per head from the
greenhouse 2.7 to from the my factory so
roughly 2 more than almost three times
as much electricity goes into the crop
in a plant factory as it goes into a
greenhouse
now the hydroponic production of lettuce
challenge is getting by and some people
are getting by but it's not highly
profitable there's no 30 40 % of return
on this stuff and tripling the kilowatt
hours per head at 10 or whatever cents
per head per kilowatt hour could be a
problem in economically but of course it
all depends on the market price all
right this is always comes back
enthusiasts will say that it depends on
the market price and they have a special
deal I've been told this so many times I
have a special contract with the
supermarket's that I'm going to get a
good price or the local market will
support a higher price because it's
people who like to support locally grown
food if it has a place like that that
people pay a little extra for the
challenge lettuce because they want to
support the local production or it has
higher quality and therefore achieves a
higher price these are the arguments
that always come back and it's probably
true then no question that these
contentions are probably true but
there's some other factors outside of
the energy input that are important so
let's look at two different little
asides and it will go back to the
important one everything I've shown so
far has just been for lighting if you
could imagine stacked raised and it
closed room being a lit 20 or 24 hours a
day you have a lot of heat no matter
whether they're LEDs or not you have a
lot of heat
if you ventilate you can't use co2 you
have to ventilate a lot if you get rid
of that heat in the greenhouse you have
the fans and you have heat loss through
the structure so that energy balance is
a little different in a greenhouse and
in addition to which the air movement
becomes a real problem and things are
stacked will not talk to the other
what's also interesting in these
pictures that advertise the plant
factories always show fluorescent lights
because it's a way to stack them in
what's the least efficient way of
lighting plants incandescent what's the
second least efficient fluorescent very
inefficient very short-lived not good at
all the one on the left shows LEDs it's
a separate question we can come back to
it additional points climates better
than Ithaca reduce the supplemental
light need by half I said do you think a
greenhouse the Finger Lakes fresh
greenhouse gets 30% of its light from
the Sun if you go not too far away go to
Hartford Connecticut go to Islip Long
Island go to Philadelphia and it's 15%
we get quite a bit improvement on the
light environment if we go away from
Ithaca which is probably not a surprise
production in a greenhouse can be
lowered by adding co2 one of the outputs
of the CA program has been a couple of
algorithms for controlling light one
controls the light to a daily integral
consistently the other one is to control
the light and co2 and what the co2 does
it makes the natural light more
efficient so you need a less
supplemental light and then it makes the
supplemental light more efficient and
the simulation showed 49 percent savings
on electricity
now therefore that was a simulation
computer simulation obviously true it
was my program
we set up an experiment Tim Shelford ran
the data in the post greenhouses you
excuse me
Green greenhouses I will never learn
that and pretty much agreed with this
now that that greenhouse is much darker
than the 70% transmissive green now so
the numbers aren't quite the same but
the conclusion was was right we can
reduce the yearly dividing by about a
half but you cannot do that in a closed
system because you add co2 you're not
reducing the amount of you're not making
outside light more efficient you're
relying entirely on the supplemental
light and yes it saves and it saves
maybe 30 percent at best so there is a
savings there but not quite the same as
a green house no matter where it's
located because my factory doesn't
matter where it's located
now these bring the salad crop carbon
footprints very close to what is imposed
by importing the crop from California so
the green house can be also very
efficient so think it back to that but
since we talked about carbon footprint
ask what does the carbon footprint
associated with creating supplemental
like to grow a food drop 100%
supplemental light what is the carbon
footprint and I'll measure the carbon
footprint express it in the mass or
volume of co2 that's given off and I'm
not talking about co2 in the greenhouse
if you're running a lot of lights in a
greenhouse where's the co2 coming from
you go down to the power plant they're
generating the electricity and they are
emitting the co2
it's a generally overlooked point now
this is data for power plant production
in the United States looking at grams of
co2 per kilowatt hour for coal for gas
for the others which of course don't
burn anything and if you take these
numbers which are still valid that has
looked at the site January and the
numbers are still valid and then the
mean use of these fuel forms 32% of our
electricity over the country comes from
coal 32% from natural gas the rest from
these other forms put them all together
an average and you get it with for 460
grams per kilowatt hour or 0.46 grams or
a roughly a pound of co2 per kilowatt
hour every kilowatt hour you burn puts a
pound of co2 into the atmosphere run a
hundred watt lamp for 10 hours you put a
pound of co2 in the atmosphere what does
it mean in a practical sense another one
of these graphs again chart we're gonna
take what they believe I didn't roll 17
everything's the numbers changed a bit
with depending on the daily like a role
that you impose 6205 moles per square
meter per day productivity 760 per
square meter per year head weight 5
ounces 5 to 6 ounces 150 hundred sixty
grams efficacy of three again we have
three moles going into 6205 is 200 to 68
kilowatt hours to grow 118 kilograms 17
and 1/2 kilowatt hours per kilogram
divide 118 is 420 68.4 seven kilograms
per kilowatt hour eight kilograms of co2
per kilogram of lettuce or eight pounds
of sea
two four pounder lettuce quite a lot yes
sergeant
now how to put some physical meaning
into this one way looked at data and
it's as of January 2014 the average Park
passenger car in the US emits 50 100
kilograms of co2 per year and we have 8
pounds of kilogram 8 kilograms of co2
per kilogram of lettuce so 50 100
kilograms women from one car is
equivalent to co2 emitted to grow 50 100
divided by 8 636 kilograms of lettuce
has 4,000 heads of lettuce just over
three days production from the
challenged greenhouse give you the same
co2 as driving a car for a year ok
when you'll go back to the power plant
again not counting the extra energy for
refrigeration air conditioning cooling
all of those things in a plant factoring
another comparison now we've seen up
down to this point eight eight pounds of
co2 per kilogram to lettuce or kilograms
eight pounds of co2 per pound three
heads of lettuce per pound 206 two point
six seven pounds of co2 per head of
lettuce density of co2 is 0.12 four
pounds per cubic foot twenty one point
six cubic feet of co2 per head of
lettuce what does that mean well you
know this big
7.48 gallons per cubic foot
multiply seven point four eight ten
twenty one point six every head of
lettuce that's grown 100% light creates
co2 at the power plant equivalent to
three 55-gallon drums I think we can all
kind of visualize a 55-gallon drum three
of them get filled to grow one head of
lettuce in a totally enclosed system
okay doing a greenhouse and if your
greenhouse 30 percent from the Sun run
from the light 70 percent from the Sun
it's down to two point four two
kilograms compared to 8.05 it's better
it's not great I've seen this also if
I'm in of Lights is eight to one ratio
two point four pounds from the
greenhouse not wonderful about three
three and a third times more co2 from
the green out from the plant factory
than from a greenhouse and it comes the
question is this sustainable agriculture
it's as sold as as a sustainable
agriculture process you decide if it is
fifty five gallon
three 55-gallon drums for one head of
lettuce sustainable
and it disregards the additional carbon
footprint well I work on norm Scott norm
Scott some of you may know norm he's a
great enthusiast about self-contained
cities self-supporting cities and he
looked at the number for lettest he said
well that's lettuce what about tomatoes
that might be different okay so I went
to lettuce to turn from lettuce to
tomato did the same calculations and
whereas lettuce had 8 to 1 ratio
tomatoes had a 18 to 1 ratio it's much
worse why well you stop to think about
Tomatoes what they have stems and leaves
and things that you don't eat they have
to be grown so
yeah stems and leaves at all tomato
production cannot be stacked as another
consideration so the building has to be
a lot taller you need a lot more volume
well and tomatoes have a higher dry mass
content so that the you're putting more
light into a single tomato into single
pound quite worried about this the
initiation of this was related to the
use the concept of food miles and how
does this compare to transported lettuce
there is a website a report David de
Villiers spent many hours working on an
energy study for NYSERDA looking at the
energy cost of importing versus locally
grown for six different crops some
greenhouse some outdoors the report is
on the website if anybody wants if you
want to if you want this send me an
email and I will send you the actual URL
send me an email which reminds me my
initials are l da right L stands for lou
d stands for devil's advocate
okay so that's David's data all imports
into New York
this is transported in various ways
point seven kilograms of co2 per
kilogram of lettuce from truck exhaust
from very others so other various other
sources of transport the average food
miles for lettuce to New York is twenty
nine sixty three and that's where people
really worried and they should plant
factory 8.05 compared to 0.74 lighting
only transporters for everything this is
a for lighting plant factory adding co2
saving 1/3 5.6 CEA in Ithaca using lassi
as our acronym for our light control
algorithm and program 2.4 to cen long
island with control 1.2 one CEA and
Ithaca with co2 control one point two
three CEA on Long Island with co2
control 0.62 using this wise step by
step by step change in production we can
get the co2 for lighting to be the same
as the co2 for imports not a lot lower
but at least the same there will be
certain benefits of course for local
production so is there a solution to the
light problem I'm gonna run over not run
over but
but people have talked about different
ways of improving the light LEDs
concentrating or whatever can his work
is it sustainable and the important
question do we violate laws of physics
prefer not to actually I've made a
career of trying to look electrically
generated light in general before
anybody asks this one is on the final
exam but just briefly what this says
Planck's law we've heard about Planck's
law the outcome of Planck's law is
theoretical maximum efficiency which can
be expressed instantaneously or
integrated don't worry about that we
have things to worry about with thermal
losses electrical losses optical losses
to go from theoretical maximum
efficiency to real-world
the result is a wall plug efficiency of
perhaps twenty or twenty-five percent
the same as HPS phillips provides data
for their leds the efficiency goes over
a range because it depends on which bin
they take their LED out of because they
test them all and we end up with a
real-world you fish efficacy near three
I use three all the way the long and if
you want to not believe it I can send
you this slide you can check my numbers
LED technologies are improving and their
costs are shrinking but don't believe
the internet surprise
I've seen ads for LED systems for plant
lighting that suggests a degree of
efficiency somewhere in the range of 150
to 175 percent truly six times as good
as an h vs six times as efficient as an
HP is those are the claims much Martin
not justified by data usually the
comparisons are against HP against
fluorescent or incandescent to make
themselves look good
depends whether you're buying or selling
and they're selling and hid luminaires
the t5 fluorescents are also much more
efficient than incandescent and if
efficiency is very similar to LEDs so we
can't do a whole lot to make the
lighting more efficient you know a
little bit and it will be done but it's
not going to be done there's enormous
change what about photovoltaics always
this is the argument that always comes
back to yeah I know it takes a lot of
electricity but I'm going to put up PV
panels do it let's look first at the
greenhouse if we look at a greenhouse in
modern greenhouse 100 units of outside
light 70% transmits if we get 70 units
of solar right through the greenhouse to
the plant canopy so it's effectively a
70% efficient transmitter about door
light looking at a PV system now we
generate electricity from the Poteau go
take photovoltaic panels bring it into
the greenhouse run lights that's what I
mean by generating electricity
panels are typically 15 to 18 percent
efficient by themselves there are 11 D
rating factors that are always applied
when you put a panel into a system you
lose something
in fact you lose twenty eight percent
standard default numbers they'll ability
in need may be asynchronous the bright
sunny day when you can generate
electricity you don't need it in the
greenhouse cloudiness is frequent
diffused a few solar is weaker but it
can be used but it is weaker jumping
through this we don't worry about this
steps anymore but looking at using the
panel at eighteen percent efficiency by
the standard twenty eight percent loss
if they got two hundred twenty three
kilowatt hours per square meter per year
predicted and we compared that to real
data and this is a pretty good number
efficiency of three efficacy of 3 panels
provides 669 moles per square meter we
need 60 205 for the 17 volts per square
meter per day daily wide integral so
that 669 divided by sixty two point five
ten point eight percent of the need for
a one square meter invert that we're
providing ten percent of the need we're
going to need much more area in this
case nine point three times as much like
this lighted area one acre of greenhouse
lighted nine point three acres of panels
no way does that work
not in this world on my world any times
the growing area a synchronous problem
by a synchronous of course you produce
electricity when there's the sunshine
you don't need it in the greenhouse or
in the whatever may not need it send it
back to the power company so I'll use
the grid as storage don't forget if you
send things back to the power company
you don't get the full price you get
only what they would have paid to
replace that energy
another small nuance I think is
important about this using renewable
energies to do things that are foolish
is that you are depriving someone else
of the access to that renewable energy
because that someone else does not have
another source I would have a source I
could go to a greenhouse instead I have
a plant factory and I'm wasting the
energy taking it away from someone else
who could use it
okay we have photovoltaic panels and I
have a choice between a greenhouse or a
plant factory and I say I'm gonna take a
plant factory and I'm going to use the
renewable energy you still have to use
your grid energy if I were to take the
greenhouse instead we now have renewable
energy that's not being wasted in my
plant factory it's now available to you
okay so you're taking it away I'm taking
it away from you the overall system is
not improved flat mirrors people say
we're gonna do mirrors it's an obvious
thing that's by the way through all the
physics no we can't direct things with
flat mirrors or diffuse radiation is
diffusely reflected you can't direct it
into the plant factory using flat
mirrors well we don't use flat mirrors
will use concentrating mirrors this poem
here says this to two kinds of lips
two kinds of concentrating mirrors
parabolic shape for a reflector reflects
the incoming light to a line if it's a
2d parabola to a focal point and a pipe
port carries the heat away or to a
surface at the bottom where it absorbs
the heat and carries it away one way or
another the light is reflected down and
collected into a small area inside of
the reflector it does not get shown back
over to someplace else
you don't bounce it over somewhere else
and concentrate it we concentrated into
a small area what are we gonna do with
all this heat and in there all the
collector what you can of course focus
if you want to build this this this is a
power tower happens to be in Spain there
are some of the United States each of
these is a little flat plate collector
reflector they are controlled by a
computer to reflect the sunlight into a
tower where I collect the heat generate
electricity do that sort of thing
this won't leave parts of greenhouses
another issue solar angles in the summer
are very different from winter so many
of these have put the flat side of the
greenhouse this tower facing south and
then think about what happens if I was
pretend I'm facing south I'm not but
pretend I am in the wintertime the Sun
rises over here goes up and down that's
fine it's coming into the South
blazing's fall and spring it's coming
over here going overhead like that
doesn't shine on the front we don't have
access to the light in the summertime
Sun rises in the Northeast comes up high
and goes up back to the northwest
doesn't shine into the building very
much at all using solar light into a
tall building like this this Sun just
you can't move the Sun now perhaps you
can put this building onto a rotating
platform but there is this problem the
reflectivity of surfaces once you get
past about 55 degrees the reflectivity
begins to go up so if that Sun is the
middle of this day in the summertime
seventy-six degrees above the horizon
and Ithaca and so we're known on the
first day of summer that angle is much
more than 56 degrees and it's going to
be bounced down to the ground most of it
we look at the angle of incidence of
South look at the angle that the Sun
comes in to a south facing surface 21st
of march south facing surface only a few
days will it be less than 55 a few I'm a
few times and latitudes this is 21st of
March April we're down to the point
where almost no time during the year
because you have Sun coming into that
south facing surface effectively May
none June none
which means July August September not
you know it's the same symmetric so we
have this problem of reflectivity in the
solar angles shining into a greenhouse
if the greenhouse is a vertical farm
skyscraper farm you're [ __ ] more
positive note there are some there's the
concept of peri-urban agriculture and if
you think back you know go back a few
thousand years not even I'd do that back
a few thousand years their work villages
surrounded by farms
they weren't imported long ways but they
weren't in the middle of the village
either they were surrounding that it's
one concept that might apply into this
question of getting local food
production a number of advantages that
peri-urban area is that between the city
and the surrounding countryside but you
have advantages less expensive land
lower construction costs growing for
building greenhouses instead of
skyscrapers the big difference there
access to the interpret infrastructure
this is important you want to have
natural gas probably you want to have
perhaps three-phase power perhaps
municipal water service is there and you
have highways put it on a big truck sent
it into the produce market one-shot
transport rather than everybody coming
in with their little panel trucks from
all over the city to your greenhouse
located away from air pollution plumes
this is a hard point to sell that air
pollution does affect plant growth does
affect considerably it could give you
several papers that show city air
suppresses the growth of lettuce by
about thirty percent so it is an
important factor scenarios where this
might work one that might be possible
we've had some contact with some Oman
for instance who look at this as a
source of food because everything is
being imported now but water is more
valuable than electricity to them if you
have a system like this with
refrigeration the refrigeration system
captures the condensate do you pull the
evapotranspiration back out of the water
and you save energy
now save water excuse me if the world is
entirely on renewable energy there's no
carbon footprint
may not happen right away solely on
efficient energy no carbon footprints
all day on fusion energy no carbon
footprint so are there possible
recapture benefits I don't think any of
these scenarios are very likely you may
think differently
anybody got a money put into fusion you
know there may be small scale
applications of course where total
closure would work and that's different
from talking about greenhouses
germination chambers the perhaps part of
a greenhouse operation perhaps not
tissue culture rooms works that's been
done for years GMO research where you
don't want transfer of genetic
information back and forth across the
structural wall Fairbanks Alaska could
work South Pole Research Station they
have one there it's a good emotional
outlet sort of place with we're going to
relax and it feels like it's back home
again for a while so I conclude as the
emperor wearing any new clothes the
numbers lie be happy to go through the
numbers than anybody wants to really
double check can we violate the laws of
physics more than a little bit and you
decide
so thank you a few minutes before this
has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu